Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we ask the question,
what the crap happened
to Rhett's mom in Scotland on vacation?
This is a continuation
as you might be able
to tell if you're watching,
we literally are continuing.
That's why Link still has an enema
on the table, an enema
that looks like a lollipop.
Well let me tell ya, brother,
from here on out on Ear Biscuits,
I'm always gonna have an enema right here
'cause as I've established--
Can you keep it in your pocket?
It's important to me.
Well I mean my pants are a bit tight.
I'd rather not look at it.
You don't wanna put an enema
in a high squeeze environment
like a pocket.
That's true.
You wanna keep in a
loose environment, ooh,
which I'll get to in a moment.
A loose environment .
I'll get, it'll make sense.
So I'm gonna tell the whole
story of what exactly happened
to my mom and the significance of that
and there's quite a lead
up so there'll be plenty.
We'll get into that after the break.
'Cause we don't talk on vacation.
Our wives--
They text a little bit.
They text a lot back and
forth and at one point,
either Jessie or Christy
started a text thread
with all four of us
which I thought was sweet
and there was one day
where I had had a few beers
and I started to--
I could tell.
Let me just say--
To participate
in the text thread.
And the reason I was not
participating in the text thread
is I was driving.
On the wrong side
of the road.
On the left side
of the road the whole time
and then Jessie was just telling me--
What I was saying.
What you were saying.
Yeah Jessie just thought
I was being friendly
and she said that you asked her to ask me
if I had been drinking.
Yeah 'cause I was like Link's
not normally like this.
I'm on vacation, what's with the judgment?
It was not judgment, it
was just detective work.
Well you sent a picture of a French man.
Well no, Jessie sent a
picture of you driving,
and she said, "Look at what I'm next to,"
or something like that and I was like,
"Well look at what I'm next to,"
and I was poolside at my second
location up in Chiang Rai,
the northern most mountainous
territory of Thailand.
I was at a mountainous
resort that was also
an elephant sanctuary and to
my left was a guy from Paris
who I took a picture
of and texted it to you
because I had had a few beers.
Yep.
And I'll share it with
all of you right now.
If you're watching the video, here he is.
Friendly guy.
Oh wow you can do that huh?
He's on his phone looking
at this video right now.
That's what the picture
is, him on his phone
looking at himself in the
Ear Biscuits video version.
Because time--
I doubt he's watching.
Doesn't apply to Parisians.
They Eiffel Tower above it.
That's a reach, anyway.
Yeah.
So yeah that was my
second stop was Chiang Rai
and oh boy, this place I
stayed at, I'm poolside,
it's like an infinity
pool overlooking the river
that forms the boundary
with Laos and Myanmar,
the Golden Triangle, Rhett.
Yeah, I didn't experience any of that.
Sometimes, and I'd look down
there and it was way down,
it was up on the hill and
then you look down there
and it was just like
what I call the jungle
but it wasn't.
And there's elephants,
freakin' sanctuaried elephants
in view, just living
their sanctuaried lives,
rescued from whatever
questionable activities
they had to be doing.
Of course logging was outlawed.
Using the elephants--
They would use elephants
as trackers, of course,
for the longest time,
elephants were used in war.
They got the big elephants.
You've seen Lord of the Rings?
I've seen it a few times.
Well I'm not saying that
that was the Thai people.
I don't know who those people were but--
Well they were fictitious.
They were fictitious
and they were on these huge
elephants leading in the war.
I went to the bar--
In frickin' Thailand
they frickin' warred on elephants, man.
Here's a connection, I went
to the bar where C. S. Lewis
and Tolkien would--
Tol-keen.
Meet.
Really?
It's called the Eagle and the something,
and it's in Oxford and we went in there--
That's cool.
And it's like,
it had quotes from them
on the walls and stuff
because it's like their
bar that they would go
and hang out, smoke
pipes and discuss things.
Really?
Yeah.
Text pictures of Parisians to each other.
Yeah yeah yeah.
We got to spend some
time with the elephants,
getting to know the story of
where they're rescued from
and how they're taken care of
and it's a complicated situation.
The elephant economy of Thailand
and trying to figure out
how to do right by
elephants that were raised
in captivity and also
to, in the long-term,
have elephants thrive
in the wild as much as,
I will say as much as humanly possible.
Because humans aren't gonna say, oh well,
this is the elephants' land,
I'm not gonna have anything
to do with this.
Within the realm of humans,
how well can elephants live?
Right.
Hopefully better and better.
And sanctuaries like this
are contributing to the care
of those that have been caught
in the crossfires of tourism.
Okay.
Ironically as a tourist, I
saw and hosed off elephants,
so go figure.
Well they gotta be hosed off.
You gotta hose 'em off.
They have a nose that's a hose.
I mean the humans gotta
come in and clean it.
Okay.
Hey man, I'm not gonna argue
with you or anybody else
about the treatment of elephants.
I love elephants.
They're very smart, smarter than humans.
Yep.
But not dolphins.
No, dolphins are the
smartest, then elephants,
then humans.
Didn't have anything to do with dolphins
on the trip so at least we don't
have to bring that into it.
Right.
So we were there at that resort.
Also took a cooking class.
One of the things--
I did see that.
That was--
A lot of the people offer--
On your wife's Instagram.
In Bangkok in Chiang Rai,
everywhere, is because
Thai cuisine is so famous
and so unique.
People wanna learn how to cook it.
Of course I don't.
'Cause I don't wanna learn
how to cook anything.
Right.
But I find myself
in the cooking class and
I'm paired up with Lando
'cause he doesn't wanna be alone
and I'm paired up with Lando
because I don't wanna be alone.
I mean they actually gave me a knife
and I'm cutting this kaffir lime.
They don't know, they don't know, huh?
And they don't know and
then by the end of it,
yeah it's like they knew.
So Lando's using the knife and it's like,
I'd hold the knife and
Lando would take it.
Good.
As it should be.
I made a pad thai.
Burned it, Lando made a
pad thai and I ate it.
Because it was good.
By the end of it I was
kinda tired of Thai food
because to us it's a special thing.
To them it's their food.
Right.
But we're just not used
to eating it all the time.
The Eagle and the Child pub.
That was the name of it, thank you Jenna.
Is the name of that pub you went to.
Yeah.
So we went there, spent I
think five nights there.
It was an amazing, amazing place.
I went on an excursion
one morning into town
and spent an hour and a
half going to every place
that could maybe have fiber
with a driver from the resort
who barely spoke English.
Didn't find any.
And I would Google fiber and
then he would translate it
and give it to the person
working at the pharmacy.
Google fiber.
Isn't that a thing?
Isn't that something they try?
That's something different,
and the woman finally
understood what I was asking for
and she came back with more of these.
Ah good yeah, it's all you really needed.
I have so many of these
bulbs of enemas now
and then we went to Ko
Samui and I'll just say
that I was on a hammock
on a beach drinking
out of a coconut.
Sounds like you relaxed
quite a bit.
I relaxed quite a bit.
I needed a vacation from a
vacation but I didn't get that,
I got work.
The thing that had the biggest impact,
I'll never forget Thailand.
I think at the end of this whole thing
I'll give a complete
conclusion about my vacation
so I'll save that but there was one thing
that I think changed my life
in the most practical sense
as a result of this trip.
And it was something, I
got a little souvenir.
It's not another enema, it's this.
Hmm.
Fanny pack.
Now, this fanny pack has
a Snapchat logo on it
'cause I got it for free.
That was the only way you'd
end up with a fanny pack.
I got it at VidCon two
weeks before we left
for our vacation and
'cause I got too much pride
to actually buy a fanny
pack and you know what,
I'm sorry for that.
I realize the err of my ways.
There is nothing better when
traveling than a fanny pack.
I mean especially if you
got five people's passports.
You got two different
kinds of legal tender.
You've got a wallet, you got a phone,
you got lip balm, you've got sunglasses
in a sunglasses case.
So you did a full transfer.
Man, I can't live without this.
I'm back in the real
world, I'm off vacation,
and I can't stop using this thing.
Okay well this is a good
time for me to interject
that I also used a fanny pack
throughout my entire vacation.
Really?
Somebody actually, I got
a picture with somebody.
Now I wore it cross the chest
as opposed to cross the--
That's a chest pack.
The fanny.
You talking about a chest pack?
No it's a fanny pack, I just wear it,
there's multiple places you can wear it.
Now it's cool because they
sell 'em in Urban Outfitters
for the kids now apparently.
I bought one over a year ago
when I knew I was gonna go to Scotland
and I got one that packs, I got--
A year ago?
I got a fanny pack
that packs down to like that
size and a whole backpack
that packs down, Matador
I think is the brand.
I got a packable back pack too.
And so I ended up using both
depending on what the day was
but somebody criticized
my placement of the pack
and that it was up here but--
A little too high,
kinda like the dorky way
to play a guitar.
I feel like wearing around
the belt did some weird things
with my mid-section and
I already have a belt.
Yeah I had to figure out how to do,
it enables a French tuck of sorts.
I don't believe in that.
You know.
Freedom fries, man.
I'm with the Parisians now.
I sunbathe with Parisians
and I wear a fanny pack
with a French tuck.
But I ended up using it
because the passport thing
like you said, it's great in the airports.
Going through security and everything,
having to reach for all that crap.
But the, and I don't know--
It's beautiful.
What it was like in
Thailand but in the UK,
they still use coinage a lot.
Oh really?
For like parking, for using the bathroom
and you're in public,
you gotta have coins.
For tolls, so I had a
lot of coinage in there.
Mm.
It's good for that.
But I kept my phone and my
wallet in my back pockets
because I wanted the quicker access.
Nothing is quicker than
the fanny pack access
if you have it properly places.
Zipper.
There's no zipper on my pocket, I just .
You gotta unzip.
Oh hey.
Pick pockets, big--
Yeah I didn't have to worry about that.
A big thing where I was so
it's like you wanna have--
But if somebody takes your
whole thing, you're screwed.
I am screwed, yeah.
You gotta diversify,
it's like a portfolio.
You gotta have something in other pockets.
Have a lock on my, I have
a lockable fanny pack.
I could get that off of ya.
I don't have a lock, I was
lying anyway but so are you.
You couldn't get it off if it had a lock.
I bet ya I could if I pull hard enough.
Pair of scissors.
Pull hard enough, pair of scissors--
Cut it right off.
That's not a sentence.
I'm just going through
the ways I could take
a fanny pack off a man.
Pull hard enough, pair of scissors.
Explosive device.
I think I could just go with--
Asking nicely.
Pull hard enough.
I think I could stay right
with pull hard enough
and get a fanny pack
off just about anybody.
I'm willing to put on this fanny pack
and have you pull hard
enough, see what happens.
Okay can I use my other
hand to press the button
to get it , to unlatch it.
Well that's what they would
do, a pick pocket can easily
just take that off and then you're right,
they have everything.
Well this is funny
'cause I did, I thought
as I was coming back
am I gonna transfer this to
my every day life in America?
And I haven't.
Well listen and I thought I wasn't either.
What are you keeping in there now?
I put the fanny pack down and I put,
I started taking my stuff
out and then we have to go
to the grocery store.
Lily's like, "Let's go
to the grocery store
"and get some stuff because you know,
"we need some stuff.
"Mom made a list."
I'm like, "Great."
I gotta make sure I got
everything for my smoothie
and that fiber.
And we get there, we get to
the check out and I'm like
I'll be damn.
I don't have my wallet.
It's I'll be damned with
a D at the end but--
I'm not good at cursing.
Once we started doing it
on Ear Biscuits, I'm like--
Oh man, I gotta figure out how to curse.
You just fed right into
a lot of people's fears.
Yeah.
I'll be damn.
Can you keep my groceries so I can go home
and get my wallet?
I usually would have it in my fanny pack.
That's what I've been doing
for the past two weeks
but I didn't think I could do fanny pack
back here in America.
And he's like, "Yeah."
So I go home and I get my
wallet, I put it in my pocket
and I come back and I'm like,
I still miss the fanny pack
because I'm like, when I
walked into the grocery store,
I had on my regular
glasses, not my sunglasses
because I had to leave
why sunglasses in the car
but if I had my fanny pack, I could have--
I see where you're going.
Put the sunglasses
in the pack.
I see where you're going
with this, this is not--
You know how I am.
It's not sustainable.
I like to have everything
with me at all times.
This is not sustainable.
Three lip balm,
I could probably fit a
little flask of water.
It's not sustainable.
Because it drastically
impacts your overall look.
It's a giant pack that
you've secured to yourself.
But isn't it cool though?
Yeah but--
For the kids.
You gonna go to a party
with a fanny pack on?
I don't go to parties.
I go to the grocery store, I go to work.
You gonna go to a get
together with a fanny pack on?
Fanny packs are for travel,
I just believe they're for
travel or maybe for days out,
like I'm going out for the
day and I need this stuff.
If I went to a get
together with our friends
and I had my fanny pack on, what,
you think somebody would be like, ooh,
you got a fanny pack on.
Would it be conversation--
No no no no.
I'm not saying that, I'm saying that--
Would there be judgment?
The reason I wouldn't do it
is because it's like whether you wear it
across the chest or around the fanny ,
to me it's like, it's an
accessory that does more
than like a purse.
A purse is something I
can hang it on my shoulder
and then I can set it down or hang it--
You have a purse?
No I'm saying I think a
man purse makes more sense
than a fanny pack.
This is a Seinfeld episode.
There was a man purse episode.
I don't know what the conclusion was.
Yeah well it's 2019,
man purses are kind of
a thing for a lot of men at this point.
Great.
And I'm saying the reason
I don't have a man purse,
and first of all, I have a backpack
so if there's things like I need my laptop
or whatever, I'll just wear my backpack
but the only things--
It's a middle ground.
I really need are my wallet and my phone.
Keys.
Sunglasses, lip balm, flask of water.
You need more than I do.
Perhaps a paper map, folded.
Cargo pants, man.
Cargo pants.
No see cargo pants are also a look.
I like to have stuff, you know?
I'm just saying, if you commit to that,
you're gonna go to a formal event
and now you've become
dependent upon a fanny pack?
What are you gonna do at the formal event?
You don't wanna go to a formal event
with a guy with a fanny pack,
that's what you're saying.
Well definitely that's true
but I don't think you do either.
No I would be the guy.
I'd be going with myself.
Okay well we can continue
this discussion later.
I mean, I don't know if we've
come to any conclusions.
I think if we--
I think they're
great for travel.
I think what would tip
the scales for you is if we
sold a Mythical fanny pack.
I think we should sell
a Mythical fanny pack.
I believe in them as an
item and I've used it
to great effect on my vacation.
But then I--
Life is a vacation, Rhett.
But then I just made the decision
that this is not practical.
I don't need my 360 camera
and all those other stuff.
But I could carry stuff for you.
Okay well then wear one.
That's all it took to change your mind?
Okay we need to move on.
Now something small.
I don't wanna do a whole
episode about a fanny pack.
Like a book of matches,
that's all I'm gonna carry
for you, like matches.
Matches are all, you ever
read "The Little Match Girl"?
Matches are useful,
she had one more match,
she'd probably not be dead.
Spoiler alert.
But first--
Oh you know what, we got a new item,
a new item we're very excited about.
You've seen us wear blindfolds.
You've slept before, well
now there is a blindfold
slash sleep mask
available at Mythical.com.
You can get it in the Rhett
style or the Link style
or both.
That's right.
Sleep with it on a plane,
sleep with it in your bed
if you're sleeping with lights on.
I have it on over my
headphones so it probably fits
a little interestingly.
Use it when doing blind
taste tests at your home.
You really can't see anything.
I can't see anything, I
can't see out the bottom,
top, side, nothing.
If you want people to feed
you nuggets or other types
of foods for you to
identify, you can do that now
with the official Rhett and
Link blindfold sleep masks,
available at Mythical.com.
As well as other stuff, TBD fanny packs.
I'm fully behind selling a fanny pack.
Just to make that clear.
Okay I'm gonna tell
the story about my mom.
I do wanna, I was kinda
thinking about what I talked
about in the first
episode about our vacation
and just realized that I
kinda made it seem like
I haven't done anything on my vacation.
You drove horribly.
I went a lot of different places.
Your hair looks nuts right now.
I think you should go with that though.
It's good.
Is it back?
It's like--
I look like Elaine from Seinfeld.
It's flat and good, it's good.
Flat and good.
I saw a lot of amazing things.
I actually, I played golf
with my dad and my brother.
One of the things that
I had been wanting to do
for a long time was be
able to give the gift
of playing golf at St. Andrews,
the birthplace of golf to my father.
It's the city of St.
Andrews, right on the 17th.
Having a good time.
Each McLaughlin has one
hole to their names.
One one one.
And we were able to do that.
Wow.
Didn't play the old course
'cause it was completely booked
even months ahead of time.
But played one of the
courses, the castle course.
Played match play against each other.
For those of you know what
that is, makes it more fun,
especially when you suck at golf.
Which--
Matches.
We're actually all pretty good at golf
but not good enough to take on this course
and have a respectable score.
But we had a great time.
Like I said, stopped
in Oxford for the day,
saw what I believe is the,
it's what every college campus
in every college town aspires to be
but will never even approach.
Just fascinating history everywhere.
And it was really an incredible vacation,
as much as it was a lot all packed into
a very short period of time,
and as much as I felt
like I was not getting
to really experience any one location
as much as I wanted to
or could if I chose to,
it was a great time
but something happened.
Okay.
Okay so, one of the things
that I had been really,
I think was the, with you it
was your dad saying thigh food.
For me it was a little deeper than that.
It was the idea, I had this romantic idea
that I wanted to take all
the McLaughlins to Scotland
as this sort of like, let's
go to the home country
kind of trip and I knew that there was a,
through just very brief cursory research,
I knew that there was a Lachlan Castle
which was basically where it started
with Lachlans, son of Lachlans, MacLachlan
and all that stuff, and so, I was like,
and I have looked, years ago I had seen
on the internet that hey
there's still a Lachlan castle
and there's still a chief
of the MacLachlan clan.
And did you do some sort
of family tree situation
or is it just--
No, I tried.
You basically know
because of that, that's
where that name came from
so you kinda know.
So and I'll get into a little
bit more of the history
in a second but I tried
using ancestry.com,
not a sponsor, to trace back my family,
and basically on both sides of my family,
you get back to about the
1700s and it's just some,
what seems to be just sort
of a poor farmer somewhere
that wasn't wealthy enough
to have good records
and there's no father or
mother listed for them.
So it gets back to a guy
named Edward McLaughlin
who was born in 1822 in Pennsylvania
and no known father.
Okay.
So it's like okay Edward.
That's as far back as I can
go and then on the Cowan side,
my mom's side, basically
about the same time,
you get back to the 1800s
and so not very far at all.
So I have not been able to
definitively trace myself
to the MacLachlan clan but I was like, ah,
doesn't really matter.
I can't do it but I'm a
McLaughlin and when you go look
at Lachlan clan on Wikipedia it says,
or MacLachlan, it says
alternative pronunciations
or spellings and McLaughlin
spelled my way is one of 'em.
So I'm like okay it's good enough.
But it's really more about the event of,
getting this group of people
together that we've never been
on vacation together,
like I have not vacationed
with my brother and my parents
since we did vacations as kids.
Mm-hmm.
And Micah, my oldest nephew,
is going into his senior
year in high school
so I was like this might be the last time
that we're all available to
just go on a trip together
and I had this idea like
it'll be fun to go over there,
we'll go meet the chief, we'll get kilts,
we'll take pictures.
Family photo.
And that'll make it all worth it.
Now, so we were in the process
of working out the details
in order to make what I
just described happen.
And one of the things I
was concerned about is
my mom has become less
mobile over the past,
she's getting older and so
she's become less mobile
and I knew that going over
to, she can still walk
and everything but she's
just walking more slowly
and steps and long distances
and that kinda thing
become sort of a concern.
So I knew that going to a country as old,
a civilization as old as
Scotland was, you know,
it's not like there's a bunch
of ramps and stuff around.
We're talking about castles,
we're talking about stone steps
that are not up to modern day codes.
So I knew there'd be a lot of walking
and so what I did and I
think I've talked about this
but I got her a trainer
back in North Carolina,
somebody who can meet with her
and basically help her
work out and get stronger
and get her legs stronger
and that kinda thing
so she'd been doing that
for seven or eight months
leading up to the trip.
So she was open to that,
she was cool with that.
Yeah.
That's good.
I mean it took a little
bit of talking her into it
but then she did it and
she loved it and she would,
I talked her to her on the
phone and she would say
I'm having a great time with my trainer.
Even the trainer kinda
switched in the middle
'cause one woman left and
she got a guy that came in
but she's like, "I love my trainer.
"I love what I'm doing,
I'm getting stronger,
"I'm feeling good."
Sometimes when a trainer
switches, you don't even notice.
You've seen that magic
trick where it's like--
The trainer switch.
A guy can kind of come in--
David Blaine,
David Blaine invented that.
And become a different
person you won't even notice.
Criss Angel maybe.
I think it was that red-headed--
Carrot Top.
Mormon magician on YouTube.
I don't know about him.
He's the guy--
But I'm interested--
He does the switch, man.
So you know, we get
there and I said earlier
that the forecast was
rain basically every day
and we experienced a lot
of rain the first day
but then it kinda cleared up
and it would rain a little bit
but we had all the sunlight
that we needed to do
the things that we had
planned for each day.
I kinda had a thing that
we were gonna do every day.
We saw Edinburgh, we saw the castle,
we took a tour of Mary King's
Close which is basically
how they built the city up over centuries
and you can go down and my
mom took all these steps
and she kept comin' up and she's like,
"I couldn't have done this without
"that training I've been doing."
She kept coming up to
me and just saying like,
"This has been so helpful.
"I wouldn't be doing this."
And then we go to Glencoe
and we do a day of falconry.
Falconry?
I got a guide to, had this hawk named Elsa
that we all got to spend time with
and she would fly off and
then we'd put some chicken
on our hand and she
would come and fly back
and eat it and everybody did it.
When I was at Ko Samui, I
went to a falcon sanctuary
where they don't make 'em do that anymore.
Just kidding.
She seemed to be happy.
So, and also on that day,
we were supposed to get rain
and it didn't rain.
I was just like this
is just going so well.
Everything is going well.
Oh yeah.
The weather's great,
and then, the next day--
To your credit.
Yeah yeah, the next day,
we're gonna go and the plan
is we're gonna go down to,
we're gonna drive like an hour or so south
of Glencoe, we're gonna go
to the old Lachlan castle.
We're gonna meet the chief of the clan.
Yes.
We're gonna hang out with
him for a little bit.
Yeah.
And then we're gonna go to--
Maybe knock back a few.
We're gonna meet a photographer
Paul, that's his name.
And he's going to, oh, we're
going to get into full garb:
kilts--
Bagpipes.
Kilts basically.
No bagpipes involved and we were gonna try
to do the MacLachlan tartan
'cause every family has
their own tartan but
they didn't have enough.
We used just a general
Scotland millennium tartan.
Still looked very Scottish.
Now is a tartan just a
pattern or is it a flag?
It's a pattern, it's
basically what we would,
just dumb rednecks would call plaid.
It's a type--
Special plaid.
It's a type of plaid, man.
Okay.
And every family has their own
and you go into these shops,
they're all around Scotland,
it's like here's all the
families, all the clans,
and here's their special tartan
and it's like the MacLachlan
tartan has an old tartan
and a new tartan.
Wow.
And there's tartans for special events
and all kinds of things, anyway.
So we've got dressed and
got completely in the stuff
at the hotel basically so
we were all ready to go.
Everybody's looking great, feeling great,
we did put--
Kinda feels like
a wedding day.
It's a lot like
a wedding day 'cause
this is how traditional,
this is how Scottish
people dress for weddings.
That's what the kilts
are for most of the time,
formal events and weddings.
And for Braveheart.
We put the kilts
on backwards.
I will say that, until then
we looked at the picture
on the internet and just,
it's real easy to fix that,
you just turn it.
Turn it around.
180 degrees.
So again it's supposed--
Because it's a skirt
for men.
Yeah it's supposed
to start raining, not only--
It's like a purse for men.
Speaking of fanny packs.
Yeah?
I put the thing on, I'm like,
there's no pockets in this.
Well there's this thing.
Jenna you can look up the
official name of this.
I can't remember it now.
There's a purse that you
wear right over your crotch
and that's where you keep all your stuff.
So--
A Scottish crotch patch.
So Scottish men
are the ones who came up with
skirts and purses for men.
Own it man, come on!
The most manly men
in the world are okay with
wearing skirts and purses.
The water's fine, jump right in.
So, she'll find out what it's called.
I think the most manly men
in the world are wrestlers
but whatever.
Well there's Scottish wrestlers.
The Bushwhackers.
They were New Zealanders right?
You talking about Rowdy Roddy Piper?
Yeah exactly, no he's Irish.
I don't know maybe he's Scottish.
He was a bagpiper.
So yeah, Scottish yeah.
So it's called a sporran, yeah, a sporran.
And so--
S-P-O-R-R-A-N?
Yes.
And so we've got our sporrans
and our knee-high socks.
Freakin' fanny packs.
Look like a bunch of
school girls, it's great.
Dang.
And it's supposed to
rain at like 11:30 based
on the forecast and
11:30's when we're supposed
to meet the photographer.
But okay, so we pull
up to the new castles.
There's the old castle ruin
and then there's the new castle
and the new castle, you can stay there.
It's got a restaurant, hotel, whatever
and it's also where Ewan MacLachlan lives,
the chief.
Does it look like an old castle?
The old or the new castle?
The new one.
New castle just looks like,
I mean it was built in the
1700s so it's still pretty old.
It looks like a house but
like a old-school house
that you might call a castle
but not like stone spires
and stuff like that, it's like white.
The one in your Instagram that I saw.
That's the old castle.
Which is still standing,
it's a ruin but it's still standing.
Okay.
So we pull up, we meet the chief
and then we meet basically the chairman
of the MacLachlan clan worldwide
who kinda took us around.
He ended up taking us, he's
the one that kinda took us
around to most of the stuff
and kinda like gave us a tour
of things and would give
us information about stuff.
What was he like?
Was he yelling in a Scottish accent?
No he actually had a British accent.
Because he grew up in England but he is a,
he's a MacLachlan so--
But was he yelling like it was like
about to go into a battle?
No, that's in the movies, Link.
He's just pretty much a
mild-mannered, well-tempered man.
Was he in a kilt?
Yes, he was definitely in
a kilt and they were both
in the MacLachlan tartan.
He was in the old school
MacLachlan tartan the whole time.
Was the chief, had a
gruff beard, a gruff voice
and was he gnawing on a chicken leg?
I'll show you a picture
of my dad with the chief.
And what was his demeanor?
His demeanor is as captured
and there he is with the chief.
Which one's which, dude?
They're freakin'--
They look a lot alike.
They frickin' look
a lock alike.
Lach-alike.
MacLachlans.
Look at that.
They do look very much alike.
And so the fanny pack is more of like a--
It's a crotch purse.
It's a crotch cover.
It looks like a bull scrotum.
Well his is made of a badger.
And my dad's--
A badger's head.
Yeah and my dad's is
made of just, you know,
metal and leather or something.
Wow.
As you can see, they
didn't hug or anything.
That was as close as he was
willing to get to my dad
in the picture.
Did he shake hands?
Yeah of course.
Okay, okay.
So we got a picture--
Is that the greeting,
Scottish greeting?
We got pictures with him.
He's a swell guy.
Is he a figurehead or does he do stuff?
Basically at this point it's kinda like a,
it's kinda like a club, essentially,
you know what I'm saying?
Okay.
But they--
A club.
They're raising money
to restore the castle.
They've done a bunch to the castle but--
Did they hit you up?
Well, in so many ways, yeah.
He gave me a brochure
if that's what you mean.
So we begin, we meet him
and then we go to the old graveyard.
This graveyard and there's
an old chapel that was built
in the 1400s that the
Lachlans had built there,
MacLachlans had built
there and then a graveyard
with all these old
gravestones, we find right next
to each other a Cowan which
is my mom's maiden name.
What?
And a MacLachlan
right next to each other
and he's like yeah,
the Cowans are Scottish and so I'm--
Really?
Whoa this is crazy.
My mom's standing next
to the grave stones,
basically about to be in tears.
She's like, "Years before your daddy
"and I ever got together, the Cowans
"and the McLaughlins were together."
And so I'm just like, I'm feeling so good
about this decision.
Validated, man.
I'm like I did this right, man.
Yeah!
Like everybody's coming up
to me about how great a
time they're having and--
Yes!
And it's just,
everything is going so well.
What about the group photo?
Did that work too?
Yeah.
'Cause that's the moment right
there when you say cheese.
We got many, many group
photos which actually
I don't have those on my
phone 'cause they're--
Did you get some
of just your parents?
We'll show them.
Yeah, dude.
And did you get some
of just your brother's family?
Yeah.
Just like at a wedding,
some of just your family?
All kinds--
And then some of everybody?
Lots of different combinations.
Yes!
Just the older boys,
just the guys, just the girls.
You started thinking like--
Jumping up in the air.
When people start dying,
these are the photos
that we'll show at the funeral type stuff.
Well some of them.
Yeah.
So we did some with the old
castle in the background,
then we did some with the
new castle in the background
and then--
Shoot different ways.
Get a silhouette.
We walked to the old castle, oh there's--
Yes!
That's,
Jenna's going through some.
Frickin' water,
is that the moat?
That's the loch so Loch Fern is the,
it's the longest sea loch in
the entire nation of Scotland.
So that means that that
eventually opens up to the ocean
but it's a very long,
the lochs are absolutely
amazing, beautiful.
This one goes all the way up.
Now what's under the kilts?
Nothing?
So I did say that I
would be wearing nothing
but then the rental
agreement stated very clearly
that you had to wear underwear
underneath these kilts.
Yeah but how are they gonna know?
So we didn't.
They gonna lift the kilt
before you return it?
No I did, there was lots of talk,
there was lots of confident
talk about not wearing underwear
but then everybody ended
up wearing underwear.
Mm-hmm, well it's wool.
Most of it was
we had to help each other put them on.
You know what I'm saying,
we were helping each other put them on.
Fastening them and you don't have
to be sitting there naked before that.
So anyway--
Speak for yourself.
There's lots of great photos happening.
Everybody's having a
great time and again--
People jumping in photos.
I emphasize the weather--
Gotta watch the come down
with the kilt on the jump.
I don't think I can, I may
sound crazy that I'm talking
about the weather so much but listen,
it was supposed to rain and
it rains all the time there
and it was literally
supposed to rain all day
and look at the weather that
we got for these photos.
Perfect, perfect.
And it just kept going
and going and going,
there's a cloud in the sky
but not a rain drop.
So then we go to the old castle,
which all this is very
close to each other.
You can see it all and
you can walk right around
the end of this, right around the bay.
Which is a little bit of a walk for my mom
but nothing too difficult.
So we get to told castle
and that's where I took
my sorta epic photo
that I posted to Instagram.
Actually my wife took that photo,
not Paul the photographer
because I posted that before
I got Paul's photos back.
But that was the moment where
we were just kinda getting,
here we are at the old castle.
This thing's been here
for thousands of years.
We've got the guy telling
us, he's telling us all about
the history of the castle
and how powerful this family used to be
and the MacLachlans basically
controlled both sides
of the loch and it was
a powerful family and,
now--
Could do anything.
Again, repeatedly my mom
is coming up and saying,
"I couldn't have done
this without working out."
She said it more times than she needed to.
Now based on what I'm about to tell you,
I wish she hadn't said it at all.
But so,
we walk around the castle
and we get all the pictures
and then, and this is,
it's a little treacherous
around the castle.
It had been raining, it's always raining
so it's a little bit slick in places
and so there's like places
that were helping her step down
and that kinda thing and then,
we get up to, we've
gotten all the pictures
and it's time to go.
We have reservation at the restaurant
which is the Inver Restaurant
which is right there next
to the new castle.
By the way, incredible restaurant.
Like award winning.
I was like everything's
going really great.
We're gonna take these pictures,
we're gonna have this amazing meal.
And then, somebody somehow
it gets communicated
that hey, go around this way,
this is the easier way out
than the way that we came in.
Like you got a castle that's
kind of on a peninsula.
You got a path that comes up to it,
then you have a path that goes around it.
We had come around it all the way.
So my mom is on the outside of the castle,
in between the castle and the water
and now we gotta go back.
So somehow it gets communicated
that this is the easier way.
But and so my brother is with my mom
and then my dad and then there's me
and then everybody else and we're walking.
I'm actually kinda filming some of this.
But then we get down to
the side of the castle
and it looks like, man,
these are like rock steps
that it's kinda uneven
and this doesn't seem like
it would be the easier way.
And we're like, my mom was like,
"This doesn't seem like the easier way."
I'm like, "Yeah, it doesn't
seem like the easy way
"but they said it's the easier way,"
and we're kinda like, just,
yeah, you're almost there anyway.
So she starts taking
a couple of steps down
and she gets to sort of right
on the side of the castle
and at this point, my brother
and my dad and I are all,
it's kinda hitting us that
there's been some miscommunication.
This isn't the easier way.
Turns out later what we realized is that
what the chairman had told us
is that this is the easier way
to see this side of
the castle or something
and it got through 12 people
through the grapevine,
somehow it got communicated
that this was the easier way back.
Mm-hmm.
And then she was basically
already almost all the way through it.
And who, who's to blame?
I mean, me, my brother, my dad.
We're all to blame and
I think at this point,
we're all just taking--
I wasn't there.
We're all just taking the blame equally.
Okay.
Even though my brother
was the one who was in
the lead and he is the one
that is taking the blame more than me,
which we're all just
like, this was a mistake.
Someone should have sounded
the alarm and should have said,
"This is not the best way.
"This is not the easiest
way, let's go back around."
But none of us did.
So we're all to blame.
But--
For what exactly?
I turned my camera off 'cause I was like
I gotta get down here,
I gotta spot my mom.
'Cause I got my dad and my
brother there and I'm like,
if she misses a step, she
could fall into the loch,
so I get down there and I'm
like on the rocks like spotting.
Okay.
And then there was like one more step
to get down to basically be on dirt.
I'm like she's gonna do this.
She's gonna make it.
She takes this one step.
Lost her foot.
Falls down, her legs sort
of buckle underneath her
and then she immediately
begins screaming and she says,
"I broke my leg!"
Oh no!
And so I look down expect--
She's screaming.
I broke my leg!
And basically cry--
Oh no.
Crying, she's crying.
On my last step.
And so 50 things go through my mind.
The first thing is I'm gonna look down
and see a compound fracture and
see my mom's bone coming out
of her leg and I don't see that
and I'm immediately like okay,
maybe she didn't break her leg.
But I do see her, one
of her ankles is kinda,
it's kind of in an awkward angle.
Okay.
But we immediately begin to get her and,
second thing I'm thinking is,
if she has broken her leg,
how in the hell are we
gonna get her out of here?
We're like way out in
this place where you have
to come down this dirt road and--
Build a raft!
We're gonna float her down the loch!
And then we had to go
down this little path
and then there's these rocks and--
Everybody take off their kilt,
we're gonna make a parachute!
And so, I think we're all kinda thinking,
we gotta get her up
and get her out of here
so I'm like you know what,
let's just stand you up
so we stand her up and she's like ,
"It really hurts, it really
hurts, really hurts."
And I'm like, "Okay, but can
you, with us kinda helping you,
"can you walk out of here?
"Because we really need
you to walk out of here."
So she takes some very labored steps,
putting most of her weight
on us but she's kind
of putting equal weight on both feet
and then we talked to
the chairman who says,
"I'll drive my car up here to the place
"you can get the car the closest."
She's a Cowan, they
married the MacLachlans.
And so as she's walking--
Hard, hardened people.
As she's walking,
we're kinda talking amongst ourselves
and we're kinda like a
few feet away from her.
My brother and my dad have
her and then Jessie was like,
"She's putting a lot of weight on it,
"maybe it's not broken," and
then the nephews are like,
"It's not broken, it's not broken."
Everybody's like, "It's not broken."
She turned it, she may actually
be in shock at this point.
Let's just get her to the restaurant
'cause we got this
reservation at the restaurant
and let's elevate her foot, you know,
give her some pain reliever.
Yeah.
And hope for the best.
Right, I mean you can turn your ankle,
it can hurt pretty bad.
So we do, we get her to the restaurant.
We elevate her ankle, give
her some pain reliever.
Ice it?
We did not ice it because,
you know how Locke is like mister expert
about lots of things?
He gets it from the best.
And so with a sprained ankle,
the latest research apparently
is that the immediate
icing is not actually
what you're supposed to do with a sprain.
I don't know whether he's right or wrong.
Elevation is definitely a good thing
so we were like, all
right, let's just do this
and have a good meal.
I mean Locke did know about the website
where you could take the size--
He did--
The size of continents
and put them over other countries and--
So we have a great meal
and I think we've all kinda
just talked ourselves into, yeah,
maybe she sprained it or whatever.
Now she's saying, "I
need to go to a doctor."
And we're just like,
don't wanna have to deal
with taking her to a doctor.
Where we gonna go?
We just don't wanna face,
we don't wanna face
that potential reality.
Right.
So--
And it's not your ankle.
Right, come on.
So now, it hasn't rained this whole day
but it's supposed to rain--
You don't wanna face
that reality, I get it.
And it looks like the rain
clouds are really coming in
and then I'm like, we need
to get her into the car.
We need to get home to the hotel
and then we kinda need to regroup.
Now keep in mind we're
like an hour and a half
or so away from where we were staying.
Oh.
So we get her into the
car which was not easy,
had to take her down the steps.
It ended up being that Jessie
and my dad were the two
best people to do this.
I'm too tall.
She needs to put her arms
on someone's shoulders
and I'm so much bigger
than her that like--
You're less of a crutch
and more of a crane.
Yeah and so Jessie's the perfect height
for her to do that and my dad is 5'9"
so he's able to get down.
So they get her to the car.
Plus you need to film it.
Yeah and I didn't film a lot of this.
I will say, I felt bad.
So we get her in the
car and I'm not kidding,
two minutes later it just
starts pouring down rain.
I was like oh gosh, I'm so glad we got her
into the car before this
happened because this would have
really complicated things.
Mm-hmm.
We start driving back, now,
she's in my brother's car,
the van he's driving.
And so I'm driving along and we get up to,
we're following the road
and all of a sudden,
there's a bunch of cars stopped
and this woman says, tells
us to roll down the window
and she's like,
"The river's bursted."
What?
"The river's bursted the road."
The river's bursted.
Yeah and I look down and
I see just this torrent
of water just barreling across the road,
carrying large things across the road.
Everybody take off your kilt!
We're gonna build a raft!
And I'm like okay, so
I'm like, "Okay, well,
"there's another way out of this place."
You could just get up a lot of speed.
Vroom!
So I turned around
and then get the map out and start looking
and quickly realize that no,
this is the only way out of this place.
What?
There is no other road.
It literally is this or take a boat.
So Cole and I go back, at
this point I'm beginning
to get a little panicked because I'm like,
my mom needs to get back to her stuff.
She's got like her medication
and I don't know what the
deal is with her ankle
but it's starting to get
dark in a little bit.
This is late in the afternoon
and we go into this little
local pub and hotel area
and we're just like,
"What do you guys think?
"We gotta get back to
here," and they're like,
"Oh, you're gonna have to take the ferry."
I'm like what, we have to take a ferry?
I got a woman that can't
get anywhere right now
and I got 12 people in two vans.
It's no ferry involved here.
Did I mention I'm an internet celebrity?
Did you think about pulling that card?
No and they're like, "You
can stay here tonight."
Oh what, okay.
Turns out they had two
rooms which would not
have gone over well.
But 'cause I was like we got 12 people
and so then they're like,
"The best thing to do
"is just wait it out.
"You should probably just wait it out
"and eventually the road will clear up,"
but then a guy comes down and says,
"There's giant boulders
and trees on the road
"and the estimate is that it
will take six hours to clear."
What?
"So you've gotta take the ferry."
So I don't think I do very
well in these situations.
I think I did okay.
I don't think I panicked
too much and I kept saying,
I was telling Jessie, I was like,
"If Mama Di," that's what we call her,
"If Mama Di didn't have
this ankle situation--"
I thought you said, "If mama dies,
"this is what we're gonna do."
No, Diane is her name, Mama Di,
that's what all the grandkids call her.
So if Mama Di was not in this situation,
this would be a bit of an adventure,
stuck on a peninsula in Scotland
and having to take a ferry
to get back home but because
she's in this state--
For her it's not, but
it can still be for us.
I feel pretty bad.
Okay yeah.
So we, turns out the ferry
is one of those ferries
you can drive your van onto.
That's what I thought all along, man.
Okay so we go down and we
get the next to last ferry
for the day.
Oh nice.
It takes us across a loch
to almost all the way to Glasgow.
It took us a long time, we
added like almost two hours
to our trip to get back home.
And I call ahead of time
to the place, I'm like,
'cause there's no elevator
to the first floor.
The first floor in the UK
means the second floor.
Ground floor means ground floor.
First floor is the one above
it, and there's only stairs,
stairs that kinda go, this was
kind of a pretty rustic place
were were staying in Glencoe
'cause everything's rustic.
Like call ahead and say,
"Is there a way to get there
"more easily, like a
luggage lift or whatever?"
You gonna put her in a--
Yeah.
In a dinghy?
What's that thing called where the--
Well not one of those, it
would have been electric.
But there was a fire
escape that has just like
two steps that she can
use so we go to that,
we get her into bed that night
and we kinda take a picture of the ankle
and send it to a doctor friend.
The doctor friend is like,
"Yeah, you should get that looked at."
So that was when I was on the phone
with Jenna who at the
time was at Disneyland.
Gah!
I ruined her day.
And you know, interestingly my brother
and Jenna both independently found a place
that was close by that specialize,
it said it specializes
in mountain injuries.
Ah.
You know,
'cause we're in the mountains
and apparently people get injured.
And so the first thing
in that next morning,
we take her to this hospital
and shout-out to socialized medicine
because it was completely
free, even for Americans.
It's free for anyone--
Really.
Who gets their stuff looked at.
And what was your mom's
disposition going to bed
the night before and
then the next morning?
She was actually in really good spirits.
She felt bad but we were like listen,
it ain't your fault, it's our fault.
We're the ones who led you down this path.
Literally.
And you know what, there are
only a couple more days here
that, basically all the
major stuff, we've done it.
We got all the pictures.
We're gonna just take
you to this hospital,
get you looked at.
If you lose a foot now,
you'll have 'em in the photos.
And I was just thinking,
okay, we're gonna go
to this place and the
doctor's gonna be like,
oh it's a sprain--
Wrap it.
Let me wrap it in something
and then just give her,
you know, just give her some
prescription painkillers
or something, I don't know.
And actually I ended
up, so Cole and my dad
and Jessie took her to that and then I had
to take all the kilts back to the place
and so we kinda separated for that.
It's like what are 12 people gonna do,
sit around and wait.
But we get a text.
We get a text from Micah, my nephew.
No Micah's with me, he gets a text,
'cause he was the one that
was checking his phone first
when we were out and
the ankle is broken.
In four places.
What?
Four places?
Yeah.
How,
I didn't even know an
ankle had four places.
Ankle's got lots of places, man.
What?
At least four
that you can break.
And first of all, you know,
my mom was in really good spirits.
She really liked this
doctor who was like funny,
spent like five hours with them.
Of course he did the x-ray and then he--
Are you sure he didn't break her ankle
in a couple of places?
And then he put her
in a cast but then he
x-rayed it after the cast
and he wasn't happy
with the way that it set
so we took it off and did it again
and got it set just right.
Gave her some laughing
gas, she had a great time.
Oh yeah she did.
And again this was all free.
They'd hardly had to wait and
the guy was super competent.
Gave her laughing gas.
And but then he's basically like,
"As soon as you get back to the US,
"you need to present
yourself in an emergency room
"because you're not gonna be
able to get an appointment
"with an orthopedist."
I thought you were gonna say,
you need to present yourself
to a lawyer and take
your son out of the will.
And he's like, "You need
to go to an emergency room
"'cause this is an emergency
and they're likely going
"to want to," because
she's not very mobile
and that other leg is
not very strong so she,
it's really hard for her to
not put any weight on it.
She's basically immobile at this point.
Mm-hmm.
Can't put any weight on it and he's like,
"You need to get somebody to look at it.
"They're most likely
gonna have to do surgery
"to get a plate and some
screws and a plate installed--"
Good God.
Because that's what you
have to do when someone
is inevitably gonna put
some weight on it and
it doesn't need to move.
So of course at this point it's like,
I just feel horrible, right,
and whether or not, first of all, I take,
I share the blame with
my brother and my dad
in not stopping and not
going down this path.
But I take more of the blame
because this was all my idea.
You know, and I'm the one
that got her the trainer
and gave her the confidence
that she could do anything,
walk around this place and
now she's sitting in there,
she's sitting with a cast.
We go to, the last two
nights we stayed in a place
called Broomhall Castle in Ministry
which outside of
Edinburgh which is an old,
it's a castle that you can
stay in, it's very cool.
And they thankfully, they
did have a luggage lift
that was not intended for
people but was big enough
for people and she was able to use that
to get into her room and I
went and I rented a wheelchair
from a place that you
can rent wheelchairs from
and then we arranged a
whole deal about okay,
well she's gonna have to
have a greeter meet her
at the airport with the wheelchair
and then she's gotta have
somebody help her get
onto the plane and there's a special chair
that you get, an aisle
wheelchair that takes you
down the aisle and then
you're put into your seat
'cause she's really not able
to put any weight on it.
Yeah.
And just very immobile.
So you made all those arrangements.
Made all those arrangements
and where it ended up is
she was able to get an
appointment on Monday morning
that she got back with an orthopedist
who looked at it and said, "You
know we need to do surgery,"
scheduled surgery for two days later.
She got the surgery and
she's got like people
from her church coming and
building a ramp for her to,
the church had a wheelchair
and then they're like
giving her basically a handicapped toilet
with railings on the side and
stuff so everybody's kinda
coming together and taking care of her
but she's gonna be in this
splint as the swelling goes down
for two weeks and then
I think she's in a cast
for like six weeks, then she's
in a boot for four weeks.
This is the next three
months of her life basically,
drastically altered.
My dad's time drastically altered.
We got a woman who's coming
to spend all her time
when my dad's not there
'cause my dad teaches law,
still is teaching law.
When he goes to school, we
gotta have somebody watch her.
So that is the situation
now is that, again,
she's in good spirits.
She's gonna be fine.
She's not mad at you.
No, well, if she is,
she hasn't stated that.
She's been very, she is not,
there's been no blame placed
on any of us.
But I mean obviously I
feel horrible about this
'cause I'm like, all
right, now I feel like
all the progress that
she made to get ready
for this trip, I feel
like that's kinda undone.
Because it's like no, okay
well, she's gonna have to,
she's gotta go through
this recovery process
which who knows how long
that'll take, I mean at her age,
she may take longer to heal or whatever,
there may be another setback
and I don't want this
to be the beginning of
her being more immobile
than she was before the trip.
'Cause for me it was sort of like win-win,
it was just like, you
know, she's gonna be better
for this trip but this will also be a way
to kinda get her into the habit.
She was like, "I'm gonna
go back to my trainer
"after I get back from the trip."
She ain't going back to
the trainer anytime soon.
So yeah, that's what happened.
Well listen.
It wouldn't have happened
if it weren't for you.
But--
Thanks, Link.
That doesn't mean
that it's your fault.
So I agree with everything
you're saying but also...
It was an accident.
Accidents happen all
the time but it happened
in the context of something that also,
a bunch of positive and a bunch
of positive can still come
out of this that wouldn't have happened
if it wasn't for you as well.
So I mean she's got one hell of a story.
So do you which--
If you're gonna break your ankle,
this is not a bad place to do it.
She got a great, if you're
gonna break your ankle,
you might as well have a great
story to go along with it
and she's got not only a great
story but a great picture
from just hours before.
But this is probably a good time
to tell you another key
piece of information.
After all this, paying a lot of money
to have the McLaughlins go
back to their ancestral home
to meet the chief of the clan,
to get their picture taken
at the Lachlan castle,
to having my mom break her leg--
In four places.
Ankle in four places
at the Lachlan castle,
turns out we're Irish.
We're Irish.
What?
What are you?
What are you talking about?
What do you mean?
We're Irish.
Yeah but--
We're not Scottish.
What?
What do you, what happened?
Well, I probably could have
done a little more research.
But who did research afterward?
That's the wrong time to do research.
Well, I will say that I actually knew this
before she broke her ankle.
Because my brother picked up a pamphlet.
It turns out all you gotta
do is pick up a pamphlet.
What?
We were in,
it was actually in Edinburgh,
we were in St. John's Cathedral.
Now okay, that was a great punchline.
I will say, we don't--
Just tell me what happened.
Just tell me what's on the pamphlet.
So Cole says, "Hey, in this thing
"that says McLoughlin on
it," spelled with a O,
kinda like how Jacksepticeye spells it
which is basically
interchangeable, the O and the A.
It says here that the GH
spelling is from Ireland
and that some of the Irish
McLoughlins came over
many years ago and became the MacLachlans.
And so the MacLachlans,
if I'm already A-U-G-H--
So every Scottish MacLachlan
was an Irish McLoughlin?
This is where it gets very complicated
because if you, it's very
difficult to research this stuff
and it's like, first of
all, within McLaughlin,
spelled my way, you go back
and there's two completely
distinct, unrelated groups
and there's really no way to
know which one you're from.
But one of those groups
went across the channel
to Scotland and became
the MacLachlans but then,
there was another tradition
that basically says that
the McLaughlins spelled
my way can be traced back
to MacLachlan but that's a little bit less
of a popular tradition.
This is very, the records were horrible.
One of the reasons that there's
all the different spellings
is that they couldn't spell.
Somebody would just be
like, "What's your name?"
"McLaughlin," and MacLachlan,
he would just write it down
and so there's literally
like 200 different ways
to spell it if you go into the book
of Scottish names or whatever.
And when we were at the
castle, there was a bridge
that you could cross and on the bridge
where people who had
donated money to this bridge
and one of the people
was a McLaughlin spelled
exactly my way that said,
McLaughlin with so-and-so clan,
and they identify with this, so--
He's hoping the same thing
you were hoping at this point.
What I'm saying is that--
What you're saying is that
your mom broke her ankle for nothing.
Or something.
No now I gotta--
Depending on--
Now I gotta take a trip
to Ireland.
Yeah you do.
Yeah you do!
That's right, do they have castles?
Yeah they got castles.
They got castles.
So--
And sheep.
That made it a little less special.
Listen man, it's--
But ultimately--
It's all what you
wanna believe.
Well first of all,
it ultimately is impossible to trace
and you can't really know
but traditionally speaking,
it is most likely that the McLaughlin name
that I have came from someone in Ireland.
I can't trace it because
we don't have good,
my records aren't good enough.
But maybe there's some Scotland connection
but it's definitely not a
definitive, like I know,
I can trace it, I should
definitely pay thousands
of dollars to send my
whole family over there
so we can put on kilts and
have my mom break her ankle.
It's not that kinda connection.
It's not that definitive.
It's not ankle-breaking
in four places definitive.
Oy.
Wonder what'll happen in Ireland.
Oh man.
Wonder what'll get broken
in Ireland.
Had a great time otherwise.
You had a great time.
I mean it was a great vacation.
You know what--
A lot of good stories.
A lot of memories, lot of
memories, lot of good memories.
One in particular but a lot of memories.
Yeah.
No one will be the same.
And you could still be,
everyone can be better
as a result of this, you know.
With her recovery, she's
gonna be much more confident
in physical therapy and
to go back to this trainer
than if she would have
just broken her ankle--
That's true.
Back and she hadn't had
the trainer experience,
a lot of people just,
they flake out on physical therapy
and they don't believe in it but she,
once you experience the
benefits of something like that,
she's much more likely to say, hey,
I want to recover everything
that I experienced
in preparation for the trip and leading up
to the one last step that
I would have just taken
a little bit differently, this
never would have happened.
I was trying to make you feel better
but I keep going back to that.
Yeah I think that the,
I completely agree that
any sort of tragedy like
this is an opportunity
without doubt, you know,
it's obviously affecting
the relationship, the fact that my dad has
to basically serve her when he's there
is gonna do something
for their relationship.
That's inevitable and the
way that her community's
kinda coming around her and
showing her that they love her.
There are definitely positives
that can be taken out of it.
And I do hope, I mean my hope is that yes,
she is going to make a full recovery
and get back into her training.
I just don't want her
to get too comfortable
in basically, in a wheelchair,
you know what I'm saying?
That's my fear is that
just be like, okay well,
I can't really do things anymore.
I'm not saying that that's
what her mentality is
but I don't want that being a temptation.
So anyway, that's my trip in a nutshell.
Wow.
I have some other things but
we're basically out of time
and that's really all
that I needed to say.
Thanks for taking us on that trip.
Wow, I'm still kinda reeling
from that left turn at the end.
And I will say that my
wife is the perfect person
for situations like this.
Like she is so good at
talking someone through
a difficult situation in
way I am not good at at all.
She was so good at talking, saying,
"It's just a couple more steps.
"Just one step at a time,"
very simple, comforting things.
After the injury.
And also,
that night we got home after
she had her leg in a cast
and the next day was the one
we had slated to go play golf
in St. Andrews and my dad was
like, "Well I'm not gonna go.
"I need to stay with your mom."
She needed help doing everything.
She needed help using the bathroom.
She needed somebody with her at all times.
And Jessie was like, "I
am not letting your dad
"not go play golf, that
was one of the things
"that you had your heart set on
"and I know he's feeling that way,"
so she stayed with her
the entire day that day.
Didn't go into town or do anything.
And stayed with her so shout-out to Jessie
for being a voice of
reason in difficult times
but also watching after my
mom so we could go play golf
because even though I was
thinking the whole time,
I feel kinda bad, my mom's back there
with a broken leg, I had
a great time playing golf.
I mean it was a
once-in-a-lifetime experience
and one of the things I will
also post on my Twitter,
@rhettmc, is I did a bunch, not a bunch,
but a good number of 360 photos,
kinda like what I did when
we did the one in here
and show everybody what it looks like
at the round table of dim lighting.
I did that as we went around.
It took me a little bit late
in the trip to start doing that
but both in Scotland and
England when I was in places
of note, I would get a
360 photo that you can go
over to the site that I posted 'em,
kinda enter into that world yourself.
Oh that's cool.
Including when we were
playing golf at St. Andrews.
Just watch your step.
Yeah.
All right Recs in Effect,
short and sweet here.
Get yourself a fanny pack.
Don't knock it 'til you try
it 'cause I made that mistake.
Along with many Scottish people.
Of course there's many
mistakes you can make.
I mean, I you can plan
an entire trip to go
to a place with your family and
be in the wrong place.
So get a frickin' fanny pack.
#EarBiscuits.
It's much easier,
much easier.
Let us know what you think,
give Rhett some more comfort.
I've done a lot but I mean
can't hurt that anymore.
And we'll speak at you
again next week, wow.
Wow.
Need an enema?
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.